- [Instructor] So my apologies.
I just had a deviated
septum surgery yesterday.
What we're going to
talk about in this video
is the notion of an ion.
So before we talk about ions
we're just going to talk
about the idea of an element.
For example, if I have
carbon, carbon is an element.
And let's say I have one atom of carbon.
What do we know about
that one atom of carbon?
Well, by definition an atom
of carbon has six protons.
So it's going to have six protons.
And if it is neutral carbon
it is going to have the
same number of electrons.
It is going to have six electrons
and that's what makes it neutral.
You have the six positive charges
and the six negative charges.
Now you could have a carbon ion,
although they aren't that typical.
The way you get an ion
is if you don't have
an equal amount of protons and electrons.
So for example, if you had six protons
and five electrons what would that be?
Well, we still have six protons.
And remember, protons are
what define what element
we're dealing with.
So we're still dealing with carbon,
but now we have one more positive charge
than we have a negative charge.
So this will be carbon, you
can write it with a one plus
charge like that or you could
even write it like this.
And this you would just
view as a carbon atom.
This you would now call an ion
because it has that net charge.
It has a different number
of protons and electrons.
What if you were to go
the other way around?
What if you were to have five protons,
five protons and six electrons?
What would this be?
Well remember, protons define
what element you're dealing with,
so now if you look at what
element has five protons
we're dealing with boron.
So this is going to be boron.
Neutral boron would have five
protons and five electrons.
But this one has one extra electron,
so it has one extra negative charge.
So you can write it like this, one minus.
Or you could just say it
has a negative charge.
So this is a boron ion right over here.
As soon as you have an imbalance
between protons and
electrons you no longer would
call it an atom, you would
call it an actual ion.
Now let's do an example
question dealing with this.
So our question tells us...
Our question ... our question tells us ...
An atom of platinum has
a mass number of 195.
So let's just look up platinum
on our periodic table.
Platinum is sitting right
over here if you can see it.
So an atom of platinum
has a mass number of 195.
And 195 looks pretty
close to that atomic mass
we have there.
And it contains 74 electrons.
74 electrons.
How many protons and
neutrons does it contain
and what is its charge?
Alright, so let's think
about this a little bit.
So we're dealing with platinum.
So by definition platinum has
78 protons, so we know that.
It has 78 protons.
They're telling us it has 74 electrons.
74 electrons.
So just from that we see
that we have four more
protons than electrons.
So you're going to have
a positive four charge.
Four more of the positive thing
than you have of the negative things.
So you could write this as
platinum with a plus four charge.
This is a platinum ion,
a positive platinum ion.
The general term when we're
talking about a positive ion,
we're talking about a cation.
That is a positive ion.
Up there when we talked
about boron being negative,
a negative ion, that is an anion.
This is just to get ourselves
used to some of the terminology.
But we're not done answering the question.
They say an atom of platinum
has a mass number of 195
and contains 74 electrons.
How many protons and
neutrons does it contain
and what is its charge?
We figured out its charge.
We know the protons.
By definition platinum has 78 protons.
But what about its neutrons?
Well protons plus neutrons is going to be
equal to our mass number.
It's going to be equal to 195.
So we have 78 protons plus
I'll say N for neutrons
is equal to 195.
Subtract 78 from both
sides and what do you get?
The number of neutrons is equal to 1 ...
let's see if I subtract 70 I'll get 125,
minus eight I have 117 neutrons.
So 117 neutrons, and we're done.
But the big idea is, and we
say atom when we have the
same number of electrons and protons,
that's when we are neutral.
But as soon as we become non-neutral,
we have either more
electrons or more protons,
and this is true of an atom or a molecule,
we will then call it an ion.
And if you wanna be a
little bit more specific,
a positive ion is called a cation
and a negative ion is called an anion.